this is the site of Hong Kong's worst
outbreak the last time a deadly virus
took hold here and they're terrified
it's happening again so in the shops
underneath our Gardens in Kowloon
there's a frantic clamor for masks the
cue snakes outside and into the street
everyone here remembers the SARS
outbreak in 2003 and there are
horrifying similarities so people are
coming to here to light up to to to
purchase ken-chan survived
he knows the fear of catching a deadly
disease with no cure
I got like isolated and turn all I was
Assad sauce I don't know why I don't
know what happens
so I remember well of course my life he
was in hospital for a month but still
lives in Block E where the outbreak
happened
hi jeans a must here more than 40 people
died all living on different floors and
unconnected he's in the same flat where
he caught the infection now with his
wife and newborn it's thought the SARS
infection was spread through the blocks
network of drains and the new
coronavirus could do the same we need to
lay make sure it is our rats enough to
block all the virus outside the air
contaminated air outside the beauty the
news that a baby is the youngest
coronavirus victim after catching it
from her mother has raised more concern
I do the breastfeeding so more is about
myself I tried to keep myself more
healthy clean the families stocked up on
cleaning materials and masks but they
know it takes only one infected person
to put them all in danger if this lasts
longer right the situation last longer
we don't know the consequences yeah at
the very beginning only one person
infected but 42 prison time people died
so this is somehow situation outbreak in
Wuhan
but I don't want to have a similar
situation in Hong Kong but the Hong Kong
authorities are still being criticized
for moving too slowly and the city which
suffered the most from SARS outside
mainland China fears the coronavirus
will wreak the same devastation unless
extreme measures are taken
Alex call for Sky News Hong Kong